it's crazy that we doubled our use of
energy in the last 50 years
we can't keep this up
1400 transport units 520 000 kilometers
per day 1750
what do i need milk eggs
don't you have the feeling we're
standing still all the time
why's it become part of our lives
isn't it strange that rays are getting
longer
shouldn't evolution make the world more
efficient
and while we're standing still
we pollute even
more why can't we focus on people
instead of procedures
what if objects start to sense and
communicate becoming tools to help us
deal with complex and urgent situations
what if all objects were interconnected
what if there was an internet of things
with the internet of things applications
are
infinite
we could be able to monitor our
transport better
winning precious time at any turn we'd
be on smart logistics as we know it
with an internet of things we could be
able to monitor from a distance
instead of spending time in a hospital
people could actually live their lives
emptying our cars would be a thing of
the past
it would also limit forgetfulness
we wouldn't even need a shopping list
we could easily ping our refrigerator at
home to tell us what's missing
if we want to be smart about energy
we could let energy be smart about
itself
with the internet of things
we could be able to manage our world
differently adding a new dimension to
the internet as we know it
the internet of things
part of our future
you